[Music]
so I turned 25 today which I think
qualifies me as an adult although I
definitely don't feel like one
I've never been in a relationship I can
barely pay rent and I'm still scared of
my parents but on the bright side I
start a new job today and if I don't get
myself fired this week I promise I'll
buy you a whole case of wet food yeah so
I know I promised you two daddies upon
adoption but I definitely over
calculated my dating prospects in LA hey
don't give me that you're not the only
one who likes being a little spoon I
want my own big spoon to let me kiss
them all right now watch the apartment
you be a good boy okay
so click-through rate or CTR of
thumbnails are based on the percentages
of people clicking into the video out of
the times it will surface to viewers
which is a metric called impression
however keep in mind the higher the
impressions number which is a good thing
might lower the CTR but in that instance
it's okay does that make sense
cool that's all there is to CTR moving
on to watch time
that's the views metric multiplied by
the average view duration got it I hope
you do cuz you're his videos aren't
doing Friday Brian it's our first day
why do you look stressed already oh no
I'm fine I'm just just excited that's
all just locking down some ideas same
it was so hard narrowing down from my 52
because Becca said they were all really
good same oh good luck Thanks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey mom what's up
Thanks my boys almost 30 how was your
day job did you press all the managers I
don't know Mom it's barely my first day
and I just turned 25 today mm-hmm
all right mama I have to go all right
eight hours asleep okay I love you I
love you too what I want here louder
I love you too mom okay honey wash your
underwear yeah
what are you still doing here just
brainstorming there was a lot of info
today so you I'm just catching up on
some work don't worry the first day is
always a blur is there anything I can
help with how do I know if an ad is good
hmm do you want to maybe go take a
little break I know a cool spot on site
yeah sure
good step away from my desk for a little
bit yeah I need some non fax machine
related ideas
Wow this is cool yeah I like to sneak
out here a lot of people don't know it
exists so what's wrong
maybe me seems like everybody else is
getting the hang of things pretty
quickly so beside the fax machine video
ideas what else you can't I don't want
to say I mean no worries there are no
bad ideas
Wow city people raising pigs for the
first time is a thing I wrote I see when
I try to think of video ideas I think
about things that I really care about
stuff that makes me upset or anxious
angry happy afraid what do you really
care about mmm I don't know my dog okay
people love dogs what else mmm pizza how
about something a little deeper
deep-dish pizza uh screwed how about
your fears what are you really afraid of
well what is it you can tell me
I'm
I'm afraid of coming out as gay no I'm
gay too
wait you okay
you don't seem gay what does that mean
I'm sorry what was that offensive okay
yeah I'm sorry I it's just I don't
really know many other gay people wait
why are you afraid of coming out as gay
my parents I don't want to let them down
I've tried to tell them a few times but
I've managed to stop myself every single
time that's probably why you're having
issues part of making hits is letting
your guard down so that you can make
things people really care about and here
it sounds cheesy but it's the only way
to do it how did you come out that was
13 oh wow
you're one of those kids brave enough to
be who you are that young I turned 25
today and I'm still not there yet I mean
you don't think I was scared I just knew
that my mom loved me and what I can see
it seems like yours does too they do
didn't you say it was your birthday
today for another 15 minutes make a wish
why does it seem like you have
everything figured out already trust me
I definitely don't more than me at least
I can tell you up a lot to say Brian and
you're in the perfect position to do it
most people live their whole lives
without this opportunity don't waste it
on fax machine videos if something
happened tomorrow and you had to leave
what would you regret not saying that's
what your videos need to be about
good luck Brian you got this hey one sec
sorry I was working late I know I said I
was sorry
no why would I forget on purpose that's
not fair I have a life too no I'm not
yelling at you you were just
you know what it's getting really late
and I have to work early in the morning
so goodnight bye
make a wish I don't want to be lonely
anymore
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi Marty
so how's your new job did you come here
to tell me about your new girlfriend
because if not I ran into Mary it with
her daughter Annabelle very pretty
steady promises no no how about do you
remember my friend Beth she has oh then
how about them no okay what I don't want
a girlfriend I want a boyfriend I don't
understand you cannot be gay you're a
strong man you lifted all those
fertilizer bags for my garden you're my
handsome son no you cannot beget one but
I have I've known since I was 15
Brian please you haven't had a
girlfriend how would you know who did
you learn this from what no one well I
just know my son cannot be gay I didn't
raise you like that
so I cannot accept this please don't do
this to your mother
I'm not doing this to you it's just who
I haven't I'm saying Brian no this is
not good gay people are sick and do bad
things they always go to clubs and do
drugs my son you're not like that your
good boy you're wrong not everyone's the
same there are tons of gay people just
like there are tons of straight people
everyone's different that's what the
radio said clubbing and drugs and
sickness have you can't listen to the
radio I'm gay but that's not me who
cares about Club me there are gay and
straight people no that's important mom
that may be partyi thank you maybe you
don't get married just be single no
boyfriends no girlfriends just not gay
I'll please don't tell your father okay
and don't tell anyone keep it quiet keep
it inside
I can't keep it inside anymore I I just
can't like you said I'm almost 30 I need
to start living my life I have to go I'm
still your son okay
I love you I want to hear it louder
[Music]
[Music]
hey ru hey yeah come in you want me to
stand anywhere I please excited and
nervous all at the same time nervous
yeah you can't be nervous though you
have to be in charge you'll be fine
what's the worst habit right people hate
it well sure the internet yeah how's
your week one so far though I'm slowly
getting good thank you yeah I'm sure
what I mean the worst thing is this
video is just trashed I'm gay and we're
not all the same and that's okay how's
that yeah that's like the whole point of
this video so thanks thanks
[Music]
good job I appreciate I think okay
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gay I'm gay I'm gay and I'm okay
with that
Brian hey I didn't realize anyone was
still here
how'd you shoot go well well I think it
felt good
what's what matters what I did you two
going on I want you to see it when it's
done but I'm pretty sure you're gonna
like it
can't wait to see it I wanted to thank
you for the conversation we had the
other night like opening up something
inside of me and I couldn't stop writing
down ideas and I came unto my mom wow
you've had a productive couple of days
yeah that's amazing
Congrats hey I wish she took it a little
better though are you okay yeah yeah I
think so
it's okay
I'm sure you did the right thing I just
want to do it understand sure she'll
turn oh sorry for crying on you in
crying any time I'm sorry I haven't
I'm sorry
[Music]
[Music]
make a wish
this long distance is really you'd we
deserve
[Music]
I don't really know where we are anymore
you were never supposed to be gone this
long no I'm just I'm tired of arguing
all the time
listen no I'm I'm not blaming you I just
yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
Hey I was just leaving but I wanted to
say congrats it's already a half a
million views in a few hours
that's amazing Thanks I like how direct
it is coming out both to the whole world
and your mom the same week while
breaking down stereotypes no less I
think you might be braver than you
realize
I think I just realized keeping it a
secret wasn't really helping anyone at
least now maybe there's some kid out
there that'll have an easier time coming
out to his parents that I did that was
your week that's all right
but it is Friday night right my dog
marty is probably yes Tammy right now
I'm doing all right probably a great
idea to be riding a scooter on a Friday
night in Hollywood sure yeah sure
okay what I owe you
so how long have you been in LA how
about a year I moved from Sacramento
parents insisted on staying close you
for years originally from San Diego
oh nice Everett is beautiful but I've
never been its home there was nothing
left me there anymore I feel that ever
you liking la so far I want to see it's
kind of lonely but starting to grow me
oh yeah I'm very school okay thanks for
the right any Connor
yeah
right
Hey
did you maybe want to come inside for a
drink I make a pretty good craft
cocktail really you doubted my abilities
no you know just let's do thing all
right okay I see you waiting till you
taste it
cheers to a new friend in LA and to many
more mega viral hits mmm this is really
good
told you it tastes kind of fresh you're
cute
do you wanna know what the key
ingredient is what is that a few drops
of peach bitters yeah
[Music]
sliced a cucumber and left cut cucumber
moment and don't forget the MIT never
forget the man
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]